in the last video we hopefully set up
some of the intuition for why or I
should say what a Maclaurin series is
all about and I had said at the end of
the videos that a Maclaurin series is
just a special case of a Taylor series
in the case of a Maclaurin series were
approximating this function around X is
equal to zero in a Taylor series and
we'll talk about that in a future video
you can pick an arbitrary x value or f
of X value we should say around which to
approximate the function but with that
said let's just focus on the Maclaurin
because to some degree it's a little bit
simpler and it'll be that by itself can
lead us to some pretty profound
conclusions about mathematics and that's
actually where I'm trying to get to so
let's take the Maclaurin series of some
interesting functions and I'm going to
do functions where it's pretty easy to
take the derivatives and you can keep
taking their derivatives over and over
and over and over and over again so
let's take the Maclaurin series of
cosine of X so if f of X is equal to
cosine of X then before I even apply
this formula that we somewhat derived in
the last video or at least got the
intuitive 4 in the last video let's take
a bunch of derivatives of f of X just so
that we have a good sense of it so if we
take the first derivative if we take the
first derivative derivative cosine of X
is negative sine of X if we take the
derivative of that if we take the
derivative of that derivative of sine of
X is cosine of X but we have that
negative there so it's negative cosine
of X if we take the derivative of that
so this is the third derivative of
cosine of X now it's going to be
positive sine of X and if we take the
derivative of that we get cosine of X
again we get cosine of X again so if we
take the derivative of that this is the
fourth derivative I should you I
shouldn't use this notation but you get
the idea
we'll get cosine of X again and if you
look at what we talked about in the last
video we want the different we want the
function and we want its various
derivatives evaluated at 0 so let's
evaluate them let's evaluate them at 0
so f of 0 cosine of 0 is 1 cosine of 0
is 1 whether you're talking about 0
radians or is
degrees doesn't matter sine of zero is
zero so this is F prime of F prime of
zero is zero and then cosine of zero is
once again one but we have the negative
out there so it becomes negative one so
F the second derivative evaluated zero
is negative one let's take the third
derivative the third derivative
evaluated at zero well sine of zero is
just zero and then the fourth derivative
evaluated at zero cosine of zero is one
so f of prime prime prime at zero is now
equal to one so you see an interesting
pattern here 1 0 negative 1 0 1 then go
to 0 then you go to negative 1 0 and so
if we were to apply this to find its
Maclaurin representation what would we
get so let me do my best attempt at this
so we would get our polynomial would be
so our polynomial approximation of
cosine of X is going to be f of 0 F of 0
is 1 is 1 and then we have 1 plus f
prime of 0 times X but F prime of 0 is
just 0 so we're not going to have this
term over there it's going to be 0 times
X I won't even take the trouble of
writing it down it would be this 0 times
X then plus F prime prime or second
derivative which is negative 1 so I'll
write negative negative this is negative
1 right here this is the negative 1
times x squared times x squared over 2
factorial over 2 factorial which in this
case is just going to be 2 but I'll just
write it down here as 2 factorial it'll
make the pattern a little bit more
obvious and then we go to the next term
the third derivative valuated 0 but the
third derivative evaluated at 0 is just
0 so this term won't be there as well
then you go to the fourth derivative the
fourth derivative evaluated 0 is
positive 1 so this coefficient right
here is going to be a 1 and so you're
going to have 1 times X to the 4th over
4 factorial so plus
X to the 4th over 4 factorial I think
you start seeing a pattern now you have
sign switches and you would see this if
we kept going so you can verify it for
yourself if you don't believe me so you
have a positive sign a negative sign
positive sign and then a positive sign
you're gonna have a negative sign so on
and so forth and this is 1 times X to
the zeroth power then you jump to 2 X to
the squared jump to 2 X to the 4th and
so if we kept that up we had a positive
sign now you have a negative sign it
would be X to the sixth over 6 factorial
then you have a positive sign X to the
8th over 8 factorial and then you'd have
a negative sign X to the 10th over 10
factorial and you could just keep going
that way and if you kept going with this
series this would be the polynomial
representation of cosine of X and it's
frankly just kind of cool that it can be
represented this way that it's a it's a
pretty simple pattern here for a
trigonometric function once again it
kind of tells you that all of this math
is connected and we'll see 2 or 3 videos
from now it's connected in far more
profound ways than you can possibly
imagine